Bonjour à toutes et à tous,
enseignantes et enseignants,
parents d'élèves également.
Tous les jours partout en France,
je le sais,
vous transmettez
avec bonheur
le goût et le plaisir d'apprendre.
Vous le savez,
à ma manière,
je me glisse souvent
dans vos pas en réalisant
des expériences dans mon atelier.
Des expériences spectaculaires
qui constituent un excellent support
à la compréhension des phénomènes,
le fonctionnement des volcans,
l'action du sel sur la glace par exemple.
Mais rien de tel pour piquer encore plus
notre curiosité,
notre goût du savoir
que de lui offrir un cadre plus large.
Dans une salle de classe
à ciel ouvert,
les journées sont rythmées
par des activités ludo-éducatives,
la nature se donne en
spectacle sous nos yeux.
Elle vit et c'est le réel qui l'emporte sur le virtuel.
Du coup, nous aussi,
nous allons quitter ces murs.
Direction
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
et vivre notre classe grandeur nature
à la montagne.
Je vous propose un nouveau programme
pour partir à la découverte
de cette région
et de ses richesses naturelles.
Qui sait ?
Peut-être donnera-t-il
des envies
à certaines ou certains d'entre vous
d'y partir en classe découverte ?
En attendant, pour échanger,
je compte sur vous
vous pour me partager
les plus belles expériences
que vous mettez en œuvre avec vos élèves,
qu'elle soit réalisée en pleine nature ou en classe,
je vous en dirai davantage
dans les semaines à venir.
De mon atelier
à la montagne,
il n'y a qu'un pas que
je me réjouis de franchir
avec la classe grandeur nature.
Alors,
vous me suivez?